والله اقولها وانا متاكده ومسؤول يعني عن
هذه الكلمه اطب المتمكنين اللي عليهم
الكلام غريب مخالفات التعقيم جدا صار ما
عندنا في السعوديه مره ما تسوى انك تغامر
فيها ليش
يدفعونك اكثر الاجهزه اللي عندنا قوه
التحمل فانت قاعد تاخذ غرامه بعد ثلاث
خطوات كلهم ما شاء الله يعني
الا انك مستحق وعندك نقص خبره وهي مثل
رسام مثل رسام انت ترسم في لوحات تنباع
ترى مئات الملايين وفي لوحه بخمسه ريال
ترى يفرق معاه مهاره ترى ليش هذا رسام طيب
لا هذا رسام عليه الكلام هذا رسام فالطبيب
لابد يكون عند المهاره القويه اللي يقدر
ينافس اللي يعتمد على الاعلام بشكل دائم
هذا عنده مشكله
[موسيقى]
يلا حيهم اليوم نستضيف الدكتور فهد
المرزوقي الطبيب اسنان حاصل على درجه
الدكتوراه في طب الاسنان فكره الحلقه جت
من مراجعه قبل سنوات عند الدكتور فهد بعد
ما انتهى من علاجي جاني فضول كبير صراحه
اعرف شلون عيادات الاسنان تشتغل بشكل عام
شلون ياسسونها كم تكلف وش الاشتراضات
الخاصه فيها وش التحديات التشغيليه
انقلبتها تقريبا الحلقه سوالف بزنس في
العياده تفاجات صراحه بالاطلاع الكبير
اللي عند الدكتور فيها القطاع والتفاصيل
اللي فيه كيف تؤسس العيادات كيف تشغله
فاطلبت استضيفه وقتها بس ما كان مناسبه
التوقيت بس ما وقفت هناك يعني قعدت بعد كل
مراجعه عند الطبيب اسنان ارسل اتذكر
الدكتور فهد وارسله تذكير واقول له دكتور
عساه الوقت مناسب الان الاستضافه والعلاج
واستفدناها اليوم الحلقه هذه اعتقد بتفيد
نوعين من المتابعين اما متابع مثلي عنده
فضول كبير يعرف شلون تاسس وتدار عيادات
الاسنان او طبيب اسنان سعودي يبي يستفيد
من برامج وزاره الصحه اللي تاهله انه
يشتغل في القطاع الخاص او حتى يفتح عيادته
الخاصه حلقه استمتعت فيها بشكل كبير صراحه
لانه اول ضيف اتكلم معه عنها النوع من
المشاريع فاتمنى تعجبكم
[موسيقى]
الواقع وشفت احتياج فعلا كثير الفوبي
موجوده ومنتشره يحتاج الواحد يعني يسيطر
ما بين
احتياج المراجع وخوفه وخاصه في دائما يقول
لك
والانسجام والتناغم ما بين الطبيب
والمراجع حق اساس انه تكمل الرحله فهي
رحله علاجيه ترى يعني كل واحد عنده مثلا
اثنين ثلاثين سنه تتخيل يعني اذا هو اخذ
موقف واحد من سن واحد خلاص يبدا يحمل في
نفسه فترى هي برضو جزء سيكولوجي جزء نفسي
وجزء برضو طبي ففعلا فوق ترى وهذه اللي
تتكلم هذي ممكن اذا صار في ميانه بينك
وبين المراجعه لكن في البدايات ما انصح اي
احد المشكله يجونك تلقى مراجعين اللي
مقروصين من خمس دقات وانتصر عليك مسؤوليه
الاصلاح واعاده بناء الثقه
يعني كبيره هذه موجوده يعني في اطباء كويس
يعني يحتاج في تدريب اكثر تاهيل اكثر فهي
تختلف يعني من
والتجارب موجوده كثير والعيادات انواع اطب
يعني مهارات مختلفه
المسؤوليه يقع على اكثر واحد يعني يكون
محترف جميل طيب على طول العيادات لو نتكلم
على وضع السوق بشكل عام انواع العيادات هل
العدد الان يغطي ممكن بعد نتكلم عن انواع
الاطباء فقلنا نتكلم عنه وتعطينا بس نظره
على سوق عياده الاسنان بشكل عام عده
الاسنان
هي تنقسم ما بين فئتين فئه مستحدثه توها
يعني جديده اللي هي عياده الشخص الواحد
وهذه الامانه تشكر فيها وزاره الصحه انها
جعلته محتكره فقط الاطباء السعوديه
وجزء اللي هو
المجمع الطبي المتخصص يكون متكون يعني من
ثلاثه عيادات كحد ادنى ومنها يعني ممكن
يزود عيادات اكثر النوع الاول قلتولي هو
اقدر مثلا استاجر لمكتب
اي شركه صحيح وابدا فيها عياده صحيح رخيص
وطبعا في جزئيه مهمه انه لابد تسال في
البدايه مثلا الجهات المسؤوله من مثلا
اللي هو البلديه وايش وضع اشتراطاتهم لان
كل بلديه لها اشتراطات معينه يعني على
سبيل مثلا المجمع يكون مثلا كالعاده لها
اربع مواقف لازم
فاذا كان عندك مثل ثلاث عياده انت تتكلم
عن 12 موقف وش اللي يخليك مجمع ان يكون
عندك ثلاث عيادات فاكثر لكن لو نرجع برضو
للعياده الواحده العياده الواحده ممكن
تستعجل سمبل مره فكرته بسيطه جدا يكون
طبيب مثلا عنده مهارات جدا عاليه او مثلا
متخصص تخصص يعني ادفان في طب الاسنان ممكن
يفتح العياده هذه ومنها يستعين بخبرات
يعني
المتخصصين في بعض المجالات اللي هي نادره
كاطباء زائرين عنده
هنا الموديل هذه ينجح يعني ممتاز جدا وصمم
اصلا
اللي هو
الناس اللي
راس المال يعني عند في ضعف للناس اللي
خارج القطع هذا
مو غرفه
كبير
لها يعني تمديداتها الخاصه طبعا لازم يكون
عندك استقبال لازم يكون عندك كويت انقير
منطقه انتظار لازم غرفه التعقيم لازم في
غرفه نفايات ففي لها اشتراطات فهي نقدر
نقول شقه حقه صغيره
منهم لانه لما نسمع عياده نتصور غير الشيئ
اللي تتصورون انتم انتم العيادات تشوفونها
يعني احنا اللي يشوفوا غرف انتم تشوفون
عيادات السوق الان وش اللي مسيطر في
المجمعات اتصور اكثر شيء للامانه
مثل ما قلت لك يعني هي قليله جدا واذا
الان ما فعلت الناس يمكن يجهلونها طبعا هي
صممت مثل ما قلت لك السعوديه فقط اساسا
يدعمونهم القطاع الخاص فالى الان فيه يعني
ممكن خوف فيه في عده اعتبارات انا اشبه
القطاع الخاص مع الطبيب السعودي كانك جايب
صيني مستثمر صيني
وطبيب سعودي يقول يلا تفهموا هذا ما عرفت
صيني ففي حلقه مفقوده في هذه هو احد اسباب
تواجدي هنا انه نوصل للحلقه المفقوده
نعبيها اساسن الحلقه تكتمل فيصير في فكر
وش اللي قاعد يصير فيفهم الطبيب اكثر كيف
يقدر يشتغل
والمستثمر الموجوده ايش هي هذه جدا مهمه
على اساس انه انت تعرف ايش الفرصه موجوده
عندي من هنا تقدر تنطلق حلو تمام فالمسيطر
بشكل عام
للمجمعات الان وكل تشتغل بالتامين ولا انه
في مجمعات تكون تقول لك انا مقدم خدمه
يمكن
افضل بس انه الخدمه مختلفه فما بيحد نفسي
بالتامين التامين في وقتها حاليا يغلبوا
تحديات كثير للامانه يعني
يغلبوا
بتامين ولا في ناس كثير بتشتغل بالتعوي
بيشتغل بالتامين حلو
التامين الى الان انا اشوف انه الشركات
الموجوده حاليا ينقصها تحدي او برضو تفاهم
مع العيادات بشكل افضل منها مثلا
مستحقات بشكلها بشكل يعني فوري او قريب
يعني تمت الدراسات شهور
وبالتالي تاخذ فترات انت عندك تكلفه
تشغيليه فلابد انك تغطي هذا واحد اثنين
انه شركه التامين تعتمد في موافقاتها
على اشعه دي وعلى طلبات التامين فممكن
ترفض مع انه احيانا ادوات التشخيص في
العياده هي شيء اضافي يعني مش مشكله
الاشعه
يعطيك مثال جدا بسيط اشعه
جهاز ويصور اسنانك لما نجي مثلا مثال بسيط
مريض تعرض مثلا الضربه او مراجعه عرض ضربه
العصب مات عنده تاخذ اشعه تلقح سريع لكن
انت فحصت في العياده اكتشفت انه العصر ميت
فتضطر انك تسوي علاج عصر علاج العصب يجيك
شركه وانا ما اشوف داعي من الاشعه في علاج
عصب فيترفض المطالبه احيانا فهذه اشكاليه
فتواصل ما في يعني ثقه كبيره بين التامين
وبين هذه
المستشفيات على اطباء الاسنان والشيء
الثاني اضافه النقطه الثالثه اللي هي
عمليه انه ممكن المراجح هذا انا ما عندي
الهستري تاريخ المرض ممكن راح عياده ثانيه
وتعالج على نفس السن هذا لان حنا عندنا
مركبه بنعرف كل سنه فتعالج في السن هذا في
عياده مختلفه وجاء عندي علاج سيء جاي يبي
يعيد علاجه
فتقول يعني
طيب انا عالج التمريض
هي تحديات كبيره اضافه لذلك التامين يطلب
انه ياخذ تخفيض جدا كبير يصل احيانا اذا
التفاوض معاهم انهم يطلبون 70% يعني
فبالتالي مات مره انت عندك تكاليف تشغيليه
عندك التزامات عندك
ما راح تقدر ما راح تقدر احيانا يعتمدون
التامين على
يعتمد اي ما يعتمد على الكل ما يعتمد على
الجوده يعتمد على العدد ما يعتمد على كيف
موجوده على الكيف فبالتالي بعض العيادات
اللي هي اصلا لها اسم كبير ممكن تمتص هذا
الشيء ان عندها كاش عالي عندها كوادر
كبيره
فالعدد راح لكن مثلا العيادات اللي مثلا
تقول لها انا بركز اعطي المريض وقته
ابغى انه ياخذ جوده جدا يعني انا اكون
راضي عنها هو راضي عنها وخاصه الان في
2023 المراجعه صار جدا مثقف سواء عن طريق
السوشيال ميديا عن طريق
اللي هو اليوتيوب جميع الفيديوهات
التثقيفيه موجوده فصار بوجع عارف عارف ايش
قاعد يصير فهو قاعد يبحث الان عن التفرد
عن التميز فهذا الشيء يجلس صراحه العيادات
في تحدي كبير في قبول التامين في وضع
الراحه وهذه خلي بعض العيادات تقول انا
بشتغل بدون تامين انا خلاص ابغى اركز على
اعطي المريض وقت طويل ابغى اعطيه يقتنع في
علاجه يقتنع في اموره اشوف وش ملاحظات
اوف المواد اللي انا اشوف انها تعتبر برضه
جوده جدا عاليه فهذا شيء يختلف في
التفضيلات ما بين العياده العي على حسب هو
سياسه العمل عنده لان انا جربت نوعين من
العيادات
الليمين طبعا تجربتي لا يعتد بها كمقياس
لكن كانت بدون تامين افضل بالنسبه لي ما
ادري ليش بالضبط قد تكون النقاط اللي
ذكرتها لكن فعلا كان انا
التامين كنت اضر اني ارجع اصحح الاخطاء
اللي تصير قد تكون مصادفه قد تكون مرتبطه
عندها جوده وقاعد تقبل التامين لانه انت
بالاخير سمعتك في السوق تفرض برضو على
التامين انه اوكي معطيك تخفيض
125 بس هذه الصراحه العدد محدود جدا عدد
المراجعين اكبر مع شركه
قبل ما يدخل في موضوع العيادات والتكاليف
وما الى ذلك ودي اتكلم عن اطباء الكواد
اللي ذكرتهم قبل شوي ان الحكومه الحين
قاعد تحاول تشجعهم انهم بيفتحون عياداتهم
الخاصه وينطلقون اكثر في السوق لو بنقسمهم
الى مثلا خلنا نقول انواع ولا فئات سبق
تذكر قبل فتره نتقابلنا تكلمنا عن النقطه
هذه انهم
يختلفون عن بعض فلو بنصنف الاطباء ولا
بنقسمهم كيف بتشوف انواع الاطباء اللي
موجوده حاليا طبعا هذه ترجع لتكسير
الشخصيه يعني تحتمل الخطا والصواب ولكن من
خبره الطويله مثلا في طب الاسنان اقدر
اقسمهم لك الى اربعه اقسام
تعتمد على معيارين اساسيه اللي هو معيار
المهارات الطبيه ومهارات التواصل مهارات
التواصل وشوي مهارات التواصل انك تعرف
تقنع تعرف تقنع المراجع تعرف تشرح له خطه
العلاجيه تقدر تسويها على تقديمي عن وضعه
مثل ما تفضلت انت انه مثلا المراجع ممكن
يمر بتجارب جدا سيئه فانت تكون خامس واحد
سادس واحد فبالتالي فقدان الثقه حصلت عند
المواجهه فانت كيف تقدر تكسب هذه المراجع
ودائما افضل واصدق دعايه اقولها هو الورد
ما كلمه المراجع لغيره انه هذا طبيب مناسب
او هذا طبيب اذا كان عنده المهاره اللازمه
المفروض يقدر يشرح المراجع حالته بشكل جيد
والله هنا ندخل في تحديات كثيره الاطباء
مثلا احياء جزء منهم قليل يعاني مثلا
انطوائيه احيانا يعني بعضهم ما يعرف ماله
خبره مثلا في القطاع الخاص كثير
بعضهم يعني في عده امور ما اقدر اقول لك
اياها بشكل كبير لكن ما عرفت تعامل مع
الفئات المختلفه مثلا الممكن هذه برضه
يعني القدره هذه انها تعتمد على المعيارين
هذه اللي هم قلنا التواصل والمهاره
والمهاره الطبيه حلو هذا بنيت عليه
التقسيم
بحسب خبرتك طبعا
عشره في الميه العشره في المئه يفتقدون
للمهارات التواصل والمهاره الطبيه اللازمه
ممكن عنده المينيموم بس ما عنده الشيء
اللي يقدر يواكب فيه السوق تمام يعني
يدخل القطاع الخاص يتف
[موسيقى]
الشهاده اللي انت عندك بس لازم تيجي تشتغل
على نفسك
مثل ما قلنا ما هو اللي يجيك مثلا في
الجامع البست في الجامع يبغى علاج يبغى
كذا لكن مثلا في القطاع الخاص مر بتجارب
جدا سيئه فيها فقدان ثقه مثلا فيها
فوبيا فيها خوف
في مثل ما معكاش كافي كيف تقنع ان هذا
الشيء
ممكن تجارب عنده تجارب بس اللي يكون
العلاج مجاني فيختلف لما يكون العلاج
مجاني
المطالبات المطالبات
نقول 10% يعانون الامانه يتجه وقد ينجح
اصلا في اتجاه اخر مثل الاداره لان هو
يكون قريب اصلا من القطاع فاهم وش طب
الاسنان فينجح في الاداره مثلا ينجح مثلا
في
مبيعات ينجح في شركات ينجح مو شرط النجاح
دائما لها اشكال والوان مو محتكر على
اتجاه معين وشهاده تفيده في هذا التوجه
طبعا هذول العشره في المئه لانه طبعا هم
عدد بس انه يطلعون من الماركت بشكل يعني
قريب 6 شهور سنه ما يطول طبعا طلع بنسوق
نرجع مثلا
النسبه والسواد الاعظم هو 50% 50% عنده
مهاره التواصل
بس ما عنده
القدره الطبيه العاليه
يعني عند اللازمه احنا واحد من اللي يفرق
معنا ترى في نسبه نجاح وفش العلاج
واحد مللي
ينجح لعلاجه ويفشل
فهذه الدقه تحتاج فيه اهتمام كبير
نسبه كبيره يقنع يقدر يقنعه يقدر يسوق
نفسه يقدر ياخذ ثقته بس ما عند المهاره
الكافيه اللي ممكن ممكن تصير معي في جهه
وتختلف جهه هذول السواد الاعظم بنسبه
تقريبا
خمسين في المئه روح لهم
ثلاثين في المئه عند المهاره الطبيه
العاليه
بس يفتقد مهاره التواصل
يفتقد المهارات التواصل ما يعرف يقنع جزء
منهم قد يكون في تكبر في جزء كذا لانه انت
تقابل شرح كبيره ولازم هنا تحتسب
الاجر تنظر منها مهنه طبيه
وانك انت بالاخير قاعد تعالج نفس بشريه
فلا بد انك
يعني توصل لهذا الاحتسابه بسيط واحد
احيانا متكبر نعكس الموضوع المراجعه متكبر
احيانا يكون مثلا بس كذا انت تقابل اطياف
واشكال من المجتمع فلابد انك تتقبل وانك
جاي اصلا هنا انك يعني مهنه انسانيه تمام
فلا بد انك
احتياجات تشوفوا ايش وضعه وهو ترى مجرد
انه يقتنع فيك هذا كله الاشياء دي تروح
ترى عرفت بس مجرد انه يقتنع فيك
بعضهم التحديات مثل
نقول اللي هو الفوبيا مثل الخوف من يعرف
يتعامل معاها ما عنده الصبر لازم
ممكن برضه
بعضهم يكون عند
جشع
بعضهم يعني في اختلافات كبيره يعني
المفروض انكم كلكم
مجهزين
شوفوا
في السعوديه
بس السعوديين اكثر
ممكن تجارب سابقه ممكن يعني ترطب الاسنان
التطور الحديث بشكل كبير والجوده العاليه
حصلت بدايه
فما حصلت ترى في التسعينات والتسعينات
مروا فيها تجارب يعني كانت عدوات
افتراضي طويل يعني مثلا ايام البارد
اليدويه في علاج العصب وكذا وتاخذ خمس
سيارات
تفر ايه في علاج عصب زمان كانت توخذ هذه
الفترات الطويله خمس سيارات خمس سيارات
[موسيقى]
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
انطلق بادخارك الادخار يخلصك من الديون
يمنحك الحريه الماليه لبدء مشروعك بنفسك
حمل تطبيق سيركليز
طيب تقول لي هذا الاطباء اللي عشره بالمئه
طبعا عشره في المئه يفتقد المهاره
والتواصل
50% عنده مهاره التواصل بس ما عنده
المهاره الطبيه الكافيه
يكون عندهم مهارات العاليه بس يفتقد
المهارات التواصل وعشره في المئه وهذا عدد
جدا قليل عنده الثنتين انعم الله عليه
يعني كسب الدنيا والاخره عرفت اشوف انه هم
عشره في المئه نسبه يعني هذه يدل انه في
شحوح ويحتاج يعني
حديثي تخرج يشتغلوا على انفسهم بشكل كبير
عشان يوصلون هذه النسبه طبعا والله اتمنى
اتمنى يعني
ممكن اكو منو ممكن معكم ما عاد على حسب
تطور من نفسه ترى التطوير مفتوح
احنا بنتكلم ندخل بعد شويه على كيف تاسس
عده اثناء فغالبا تحتاج المهارتين هذه
المهاره الطبيه والمهارات التواصل فشنطه
نفسك فيها للطبيب الحين قاعد يسمع يقول
طيب ما هذا الطبيه انت اوكيه ممكن تروح
تحضب دورات في المؤتمرات العالميه
سواء في السعوديه في شيء اسمه
هذه تشترك فيها يعطونك مثلا ورش عمل ورش
عمل يعطيك مثلا
يعني
مهاره معينه تبدا تجمع تجمع مهارات كثيره
هذه معروفه عند الاطباء معروفه وكل
المؤتمرات سواء الداخليه والخارجيه قاعد
تعمل عليها
فمن هنا تقدر تطور من نفسك في المهاره
الطبيه والمهاره التواصل مهاره التواصل
ممكن ترى تحضر خطاب
اذا عندك مثلا
تحضر السوشي يعني
فعاليات اجتماعيه تقدر تنطرق في هذا
الاتجاه تحضر دورات ما في مانع ما يمنع
ترى انت لابد تكون ملم بكل شيء
مهارات التواصل
وبالاضافه الى ذلك المهارات مع المجتمع لا
بد انك تصل
وبداياتك في العياده ترى ما هي بنفسنا بعد
مثلا خمس سنوات سبع سنوات بدا ياتي اكيد
راح تشوف الاخطاء تحللها تحاول تطول من
نفسك يا اخي ما عرفت تقنع المراجع هذا
الزياره الثانيه تجنب الخطا اللي وقعت فيه
اروح اسال ترى الانسان لما يكون هو حريص
وعنده الشغف للتطوير راح يوصل
عرفت فبالتالي هذه الاشياء اللي تقدر انت
منها تنطرق ترى حلو الان نتكلم على موضوع
تاسيس عياده قبل ما ادخل الموضوع ممكن نمر
بشكل سريع على برنامج خبير
عن وزاره الصحه
بس نبذه عن برنامج خبير وش ممكن
يضيف للاطباء وبعدين ندخل على موضوع
التاسيس العيادات للامانه في كثير يعني
نشاطات وفيه
تحركات يعني سريعه وعلى يعني خطوات سريعه
في القطع الخاص
لسرعه الوصول فيه للمرحله التطوير ونرجع
لمنافس افضل من القطاعات الثانيه اللي هي
الحكوميه وغيرها او شبه حكوميه
فلو نرجع برضو نشوف مثلا
الوزراء مثلا اغلبهم مثلا من قطاع الخاص
هم فاهمين الديناميكيه اقطار خاصه عشان
كذا في قرارات قاعد تؤخذ قرارات جريئه
ممتازه ترفع الجوده
تفيد الاطباء اللي هم على راس العمل في
الحكومه فمنها مثلا برنامج خبير مثلا منها
مثلا امتيازات السريه هذه كلها برامج
جرت الواقع حللته اتخذت قرار برنامج خبير
برنامج خبير هو استحاله
بالاستشاريين السعوديين اللي يعملون في
قطعه الحكوميه طبعا هو على انه يبتدي
مراحل ويبتدي في المستقبل انه يغطي شرائح
اخرى بس حاليا يغطي شريحه هنا يفيد حاجتين
يفيد اول شيء الاستشاري السعودي على راس
العمل انه انا ما راح اجلس لان اتقاعد
وبعدين ابحث عن وظيفه في القطاع الخاص وقت
انا كبرت المهارات قلت عندي
يختلف تمام القطاع الخاص يحتاج مهارات
خاصه ما هي موجوده
شوف
المخزونه الاستراتيجي
للاطباء الاستشاريين ترفاحكم لما نرجع مثل
الابتعاث والافاد الحكومه دفعت مبالغ جدا
ضخمه في تطوير السعودي المنافس على مستوى
العالم ولا احد يقدر ينكر هذا الشيء
بما فيهم ناس يتعجون في امريكا ترى يبحثون
عن الجوده السعوديه
فالسشاري السعودي بس انه ترى برضو كلمه
نطلقها بشكلها العام هذا نرجع للتفصيل
فنشوف اكثرهم في الحكومه اكثرهم في
الحكومه بس انه ترى ممكن الاستشاري برضو
ترى متمكن هذه نقطه لازم نفهم
عنده المهارات القليله فانت لازم بس
السواد الاعظم اللي هم على التدريب عالي
هم موجودين في القطاع الحكومي من هنا جاء
انه اوكي نسمح له انه نشتغل في القطاع
الخاص منها اول شيء يكتسب الجراءه ويعرف
ايش القطاع الخاص القطاع الخاص بالنسبه
للموظف الحكومي ترى صندوق اسود ما يعرف عن
شيء
ممكن هو ينتقل بعدين هو لا يشتغل الخبير
انه يشتغل في عياده من عيادات القطاع
الخاص وكم ممنوعون بس الاعضاء التدريس من
جامعه حكوميه كان اللي يسمح لهم الان
للجميع مسموح له بس انه لا بد يكون عنده
سنتين خبره
يعني كاسه شعري ويتم موافقه جهه العمل
على انه ما يتعارض وقاتل العمل في قطاع
خاص مع قطاع حكومي تحدد الايام اللي بيروح
يشتغل فيها فلها ضوابط معينه على اساس انه
ما يقل تقل انتاجيته في القطاع الحكومي
بسوي نفسه اللي يسويه في الحكومي
مره طويله في العلاج مجاني
كل واحد عنده 32 سنه انت لو تحسبها عشره
صار عندها 320
مثلا التكرار على نفس المريض فترات قصيره
يطورك بشكل افضل طبعا المثل اداره الوقت
مثلا في الحكومه متى يطول يطول يطول مثلا
الطبيب مع المراجع لكن في القطاع الخاصه
محسوبه عليه الدقيقه
بالتالي لابد انك تقدم جوده العلاج في
اقصر وقت ممكن بس ما هو يعني اثر الوقت
هذا على الجوز لازم توزنها بس مو مثلا
تجلس مع مختص ساعه تروح تسمع ساعتين حلو
مو بساعتين تشرح المريض المهارات تطول معك
لانه هذه كعدد وكواليتي تقدر تحس بقيمتها
في القطاع الخاص فالقطاع الخاص لما يجبرك
تدير وقتك بشكل افضل خليك تمارس اكثر
والتالي وهذه اكبر تحديات تواجه السنين
السعوديين بعد التقاعد لما يدخل لانه خلاص
اتعود على وقت معين تعود عائلته معين ما
يعرف مهاره التواصل مع المراجع في اقناعه
ترى غير موجوده بنسبه يعني مهيب قليله
صراحه عند الشريم الحكوميين بعد الدقائق
فهذا سهل انه منخرطوم في القطاع الخاص
اوكي نستفيد منك كمهارات
انت تطلع القطع الخاص وتعرف وش القطاع
الخاص وش يقدم ممكن انت تقتنع برضو وتفيد
القطاع الخاص انك تنتقل بشكل كامل او انك
تبقى على راس عملك وتمارس هذا فهذا الشيء
يوفر اول شيء رفع جوده القطاع الخاص من
ناحيه الاطباء اللي عندهم مهارات كبيره
تموفر لانه سحب الان من
سمح للقطاع الحكومي انه يوفر هذه الخدمه
فبالتالي صار في اطباء برضو متمكنين كثير
الان
جزئيه النوم مسموح ليفتح بزنس عادي
لا موظف حكومي
خبير تقدر تصير موظف غطاء خاص وتقدر تفتح
عياده ايضا انك تشتغل عند ناس في عيادات
يعني بس مو مسموح لك انت لانك ما تفتح
فلازم تتعامل مع مستثمر يصير هو اللي
عياده مو جمع طبي سواء كان طبيب او مستثمر
عن عاده واحده واحد بياخذ
طبيب حكومي الان استشاري يبغى يفتح له غير
مسموح له ما يقدر مسموح لك يا خبير نشتغل
في المجمعات بس مجمعات اذا كانت عيده
واحده من هذه الطبيب متفرق تماما
مجال ياخذ عياده وحده اوكي هذا من زمان
موجوده هذه مستحدثه من سنتين خصصت للاطباء
السعوديه فقط حلو بس هم اللي كانوا
متفرغين
او قصدك
مسجل في وظيفه حكوميه بس قصدي يعني اذا
كان يشتغل فيه غير قطاع خاص يقدر في حياته
تفرق من العمل الحكومي ليس متفرغ من العمل
تمام
بعد شويه عن موضوع الكوادر نفسها وكيف
تستقطبها العياده مع ذلك بس خلينا
بالامتيازات برضه قدمت مثلا وزاره الصحفي
بموضوع الامتيازات الامتيازات امتيازات
السريه امتيازات السريه
اول كان مثلا علاج العصب
الخلاء
يعني في تخصصات معينه كانت ممنوع الطبيب
العام انه يمارسها يعني الا في حدود معينه
مثلا اجي عصب قناه واحده او قناتين كحد
اقصى تلبيسه تلبيس مثلا بتركيبات يسوي
تركيبه واحده او تلبيسه واحده مثلا في
الخلع مسموح لعدد يعني ما يكون جراحي ما
يكون كذا لانه مهاراته هو يعطيك تعطيك
الجامعه يعني فبالتالي كان اللي يطور من
نفسه
نظاما قد يحاسب لو تجرؤ وحاولوا تسوي اكثر
من حتى دورات تدريبيه
ومعتمده وكذا يبلش ما يقدر نظامه فالان جت
امتي مقرات السوق والقطاع الطبي فسمح
للاطباء
بشكل عام انه خذ دورات معتمده وتعال تحت
اشراف اللي هو استشاري سعودي في المجمع
برضه في المجمع خاصه في المجمع في العياده
او مثلا في العياده ويكون معك استشاري
زائر مثلا كنت تحت اشرافه فيسمح لك انك
تمارس انك مثلا تسوي اكثر من تلبيسه مسموح
لكي تسوي اكثر من علاج عصب مسموح لك بس
اللهم يكون معك شهادات دورات معتمده فلازم
استشاري ولا بس استشاري يشرف عليك طيب لو
ما في مرحله خلاص ما تحتاج استشاري لا الا
ان يكون معك شهادات دراسات عليا
انك تصير تحت يكون تحت تحت اشراف استشاري
حلو فهذه
انه بتقدر
كان انت محدود انك ما تتعدل لمت هذا مبتدع
مثلا متوسط لا ما توصل المهارات المتوسط
ممكن انت تنطلق الطبيب العام حريه اكبر في
القطاع الخاص انه احضر دورات واطور من
نفسي فبالتالي انتج فيزيد دخلي فيصير عندي
حياه افضل فرصه افضل فهذه الفكره موقف زي
كذا طبعا رجعت مع كثير
[ضحك]
الطبيب كان بيحاول يعالج اسناني وبعدين
مدري ايش كان مره على شيء في الاسنان قال
لي ما اقدر اشتغل عليه يعني لازم اجيب لك
احد ثاني هو التخصصه هو اللي يشتغل على
الشغله هذه اني انا من وجهه نظري كانت
سهله
الموضوع انت تستطيع انت تقدر ههه
رحم الله فقد نفسه هذا الشيء مره ايجابي
عند الطبيب هذا وهني انه فعلا انت ممكن
توصل الحالات المتقدمه ما تقدر خلاص الا
دوراتك تفيدك ولا
خلاص شوف الناس المتخصصه في تخصص الدقيق
هذه تساعدك اهم شيء مثل ما قلت لك
مفتاح نجاحك اصلا في قطاع الخاص هو حاجتين
مفتاح الاول الامانه والمفتاح الثاني هو
الصدق فلا بد انك تكون امين وصادق هذا
الشيء اللي راح اصلا يجيبك النجاح بدون ما
تتعب فيه بدون ما تتعب فيه راح يجيك فلابد
انك تعرف مثلا او القصور عندك
وتدور من
يساعدك صادق يعني اذا الشيء فيه الم تقول
فيه الم اذا في الم الم اكيد
[ضحك]
كم ممكن تكلفني بشكل عام والله شفت فيه
تكاليف الاوليه اللي هي تكاليف تاسيسيه
وبعدين طلق التكاليف التشغيليه
[موسيقى]
التحديات كبير كانك تقول تعال انت موظف
ابغى اكتب لي بيت
تسوي تشرف على جبس الامور تحديات كبيره
فما كلنا يعني وخاصه الاطب اللي مثلا يعني
نغمسوا في الدراسه سنوات طويله وراحوا ما
يقدم لا يتقنون هذه المهارات فانت تبي
تاسس عياده اول شيء حدد ايش وجهتك لازم
تعرف وش تبين وقديش خبراتك قبل ما تفكر في
العياده هل خبرتك خمس سنوات الى سبع سنوات
في القطاع الخاص او لا اذا ما اذا عندك
هذا الاجابه
نعم اوكي ممكن تفكر انك تفتح لا وقف راح
خذ خبره اعرف ايش الوضع
يتطلب وش المهارات اللي تحتاجها لانك انت
بالاخير راح تصير الكل في الكل في البدايه
على طول تطلع من الحكومه وتحاول الوضع
وهذا فكره خبير انها قاعده تساعدك تمام
وحتى الاطباء اللي هم توهم متخرجين وكذا
الدعوه ما هي افتح على طول تراها تحديات
كبيره
فلا بد انك في البدايه تاخذ خبره من خمس
سنوات سبع سنوات بعد هذه الخبره اوكي عندك
هذه الخبره ممكن تفكر هل انا قدرتي
الماديه كبيره ولا قدره الماديه على قدي
لما نتكلم عن جدي ترى احنا نتكلم 700 الف
الى مليون او تقدر اكثر ثلاثه مليون
الاربعه مليون هذا من اطلاعك هذا اقل شيء
عشان تدعى يده يعني مثلا كعياده من 700
الف مليون يعتمد على الفينشنج بس اذا
بختار يعني
بختار مكتب اسوي فيه عياده اي مكتب عادي
ولا في اشتراطات معينه مثل ما قلت لك يعني
اول شيء لازم تتاكد من البلديه لا تروح
وتوقع ههه اللقطه
وزاره الصحه كمساحه مثلا غرفه التعقيم
عندك غرفه نفايات الطبيه عندك
العياده لها مساحه معينه ممكن المساحه ما
تكفيك اصلا في اشتراطات من وزاره الصحه
على مساحات العياده متاكد المكتب
او مثلا
لابد طبعا فكره العياده ترى فيها امور
يعني سهله اكثر من مجمع مره سهله عشان كذا
انا اشجع صراحه هذه الفكره واهنيها يعني
خصصتها لطب السعوديه
المجال بشكل مره كبير
اول حاجه لما نتكلم مثلا عن التكلفه
اساسيه نتكلم منها اقل مثلا من 700 الى
مليون المكاتب بسهوله تحصل مثلا حق طويل
الامد عشر سنوات 15 سنه
لكن في المجمع انت قاعد تنافس انشطه
تجاريه كثير
خمس سنوات يلا تحصل الى سبع سنوات ما تحصل
عقود طويله وهذه مهمه بالنسبه لك لان تفرق
معك بعدين في التجهيزك مجمع العيادات ولا
العياده ممكن تحصل يعني المكتب ممكن تحصل
طويل عقد طويل الامد يعني عشر 15 سنه ممكن
مكاتب كبيره
عندكم او انك تسوي
طبعا هذا مو ولا انصح فيه اصلا ولا لانه
لها يعني قصور مره كبير انك تروح العياده
تقول هذا الشيء
لك وللمجمع ممكن المجمع اصلا غير ناجح في
ادارته غير كذا فانت ملتزم انك تاخذ عندهم
بعقد ايجار الاداره احيانا قد تكون غير
جيده فما انصح بهذا التوجه لكن مثلا انت
كعياده تروح تفتح عياده في مكتب في عماره
مكتبيه عماره تجاريه ممكن تفتح فيها عياده
العياده هذه
اذا فتحتها التكلفه عليك اقل عقودك تقدر
تحصل سنوات اطول
ثاني مجمع طبي متخصص جمع طبي متخصصه لازم
عيادات كبيره ومساحات كبيره فبالتالي انك
تحصل عقود طويله امد هذه ليش ما تستاجر زي
المكاتب سنتين ثلاثه ممتاز طبعا هذه قودنا
الى انك انت بالاخير سمعتك ترى ما راح
تطلع على طول ممكن ثلاثه يلا تغطي تكاليفك
التشغيليه وبعد زين تبدا تطلع عاد
تحقق الارباح سمعتك صار معروفه مشهوره
طبيب ناجح وعنده
وراجعين كثير فبالتالي انك التنقل هذا راح
يتعبك او تروح يقلل عليك وبعدين اصلا
العياده انت لما تدخل اي عياده اسنان لا
تتوقع انها سهله الانشاء
ترى تحت الارض في شبكات مره تكاليف هذه
انت تقول 700000 الى مليون وين كثير كثير
اول شيء عندك جزء منها ايجار جزء منها
مثلا تمديدات تحت الارض انت كل عياده
تحتاج مثلا تمديدات مياه تمديدات صرف
تمديدات
هواء تمديدات كهرباء يعني يمكن كل عيال
تحتاج خمس مواسير لست مواسير تحت الارض
فبالتالي هذا لها مكان خارجيه فبالتالي لا
تشوفوا عياده تحسب الكرسي قاعد يشتغل وحده
لا في اجهزه برا قاعد
في اجهزه خارجيه فبالتالي مكلفه هذه
عمليات تمديداتها في الارض فما هي سهله
ترى انك
تنشف عشان كذا اقول لك هل تسوى عليك ولا
ما تسوى سنتين ثلاث اوكي طيب نقطه ثانيه
حتفرق معانا
نقطه ثانيه يعني الارضيه لازم تمد عليها
وبعدين تروح تبلط بعدين تروح تسوي وبعدين
توفر اجازتك الاجهزه هلا بروح يسار افضل
الاجهزه ولا اجهزه جودتها يعني مقبوله
واشتغل فيها لان هنا النقطه مره مهمه اللي
هي انه ترى لو تاخذ افضل الاجهزه يفصل
المشروع لا قدر الله ترمت به
برخصه فلوس مالها زبون مالها زبون ما في
احد عياده ثانيه تحتاجه زبون صعب انك
تحصله زبون صعب كانك تقول له بتبيع نورس
بنفسجي
نزل فكره
هذا الموقف اذا عندك طويل عقد طويل امد
ايه ما عندي مانع مستثمر هذا يعتبر
استثمار اختار اجهزه طبيه ما ابغى الصيانه
انا بيعطوني ضمان مثلا في الاجهزه مثلا
الكوريه او غيرها مثلا 60
تمشي معاي لكن بعد سنتين الصيانه مكلفه
حتكون علي اذا عقد طويل امد انا حابحث
الاجهزه مثل الاوروبيه الامريكيه انه تعيش
معي بدون صيانه او صيانتها قليله
[موسيقى]
ثمانيه تكتب نشرات بريديه متنوعه ذكيه
وممتعه خليك على الاطلاع بالتخصص اللي
يهمك والمواضيع اللي تشدك وتساعدك تكتشف
اهتمامات جديده تعرف على نشراتنا عن
الحياه اليوميه والافلام والكتب حتى كوالي
اشتركت اللي يناسبك منها بتوصلك على بريدك
مباشره نترك لك رابط الاشتراك في الوصف
[موسيقى]
تمشي معك ممتازه ترى في البدايه لكن تكلفه
الصيانه بعدين حتطلع عليك يعني لو تشتري
جهاز ثاني افضل
بتاكل منها
اكيد فانت لازم تحدد اهدافك هل عندك مثلا
طويل امد اوكي باخذ اجهزه قوه تحملها عالي
عشان اوفر في الصيانه في المستقبل انا
قاعد استثمر عندك اجهزه العياده في اتصور
تمديدات هذه كلها بتروح بكفاني في العياده
انت مثلا تمديدات بتروح خارج المبنى على
اساس انه عندك مكائن خارجيه
شفط فهذي تكلفتها تكلفتها عندك اجهزه
تعقيم عندك اجهزه الاشعه عندك اجهزه صغيره
مثل اجهزه علاج العصا جهاز تصلب الحشوات
في اجهزه كثير ترى انت لو بتدخل عياده
الاسنان شبهها كانها غرفه عمليات مواد
كثير مواد كثير بس كلها نقدر نمشي فيها في
الاجهزه الثانيه بنفس القاعده الامريكي
الاوروبي هو الافضل يتحمل
يعني هذه لازم تضبطها صح يعني مثلا نقول
التعقيم لا تلعب فيه
تعقيم افضل شيء دائما حتى لو ان عقلك
اول حاجه لانه ترى مخالفات التعقيم جدا
صار ما عندنا في السعوديه مره صارمه ما
تسوى انك تغامر فيها ليش
يدفعونك اكثر الاجهزه اللي عندنا قوه
التحمل لا بس ليش في تركيز على التعقيم
تحديدا يعني على اساس لانه ترى هذه مثل اي
عيادات فيها انتقال العدوى وكذا فبالتالي
لابد انه تحرص على الموضوع هذا يعني في
جولات الرقابيه وتفتيشيه صارمه في هذا
الموضوع يعني كل شيء ممكن يتهاونوا معك
ويعطونك فيه انذارات الا تعقيب على طول
عشره الاف عشرين الف تحاول توفر في
التعقيد لا تحاول ولا تحاول انك مره
الاشياء ممكن انت تاخذ كوري تاخذ
الماني يعتمد على اول امريكا وهي شركه
ثانيه بس انه
حاول انك تعرف يعني اذا مثلا قطع غيار
المتوفره دائما الى الالماني اكثر شيء
لانه من زمان موجود عندك مثلا كراسي يعتمد
برضو على عقدك كذا مثلا عقدك طويل امد
ممكن الالماني الامريكي
لكن مثلا عقدك قصير اتجه للكوري الصيني
لانك انت برضو ترى ما عندك
هي تحديات مقبله يعني هل انت تقدر اوكي
راح تكون قد التحدي في اداره بشر في اداره
مراجعين مشاكل مراجعين راح تعرفها راح
تحلها محاسبين
مشتريات
مبيعات يعني ترى تحديات كبيره فبالتالي
انت لازم في البدايه بحذر هذي كلها
الاجهزه الحين المواد طيب
انا اشبه
عشان نبسط الصوره اكثر
[موسيقى]
اشبهك كان عندك مطعم تمام المطعم
الزبون جاك يبحث عن مثلا غدا او عشاء معين
فتح تطبخ له عندك مطبخ رئيسي حتطبخ لهذه
الوجبه عندك ادوات الطبخ القدر كذا
الملائك سواء كانت امريكيه اوروبيه كوريه
صينيه انت طباخ ماهر حتطبخ طبختك صح
والزبون حياخذ الاكله انت احرص عن الاكل
مثلا
اللي هو المقادير او اللي هي مكونات تكون
فعلا من افضل شيء الخضار والاشياء هذه لان
هذا الزبون حياخذها بحياتي لها لكن مثلا
ادوات الطبخ سواء كانت امريكيه اوروبيه
صغيره هذه ما حد تفرق مع زبون ترى هي
بالاخير انه ممكن قدر ما تحمل وانكسر
من العجم
انت احرص على المواد اللي حياخذها المراجع
انها افضل شيء لا تقام باسمك ودائما احنا
انت قصدك المواد اللي تصير معه ياخذها برا
العيال
بعيش معها انك دائما حط نفسك
واحنا بالاخير مثل ما قلت لك لازم انت تحس
باجر الدنيا والاخره فبالتالي انه اتمنى
هذا الخدمه ياخذ النفسي او
القريبة ومربوطه مثل ما
انت تقدر تختار شركات كثيره وكلام صرحه
غذاء والدواء تتواجد انه تتواجد وافقت
معايير
فبالتالي تقدر انت تاخذ منها يعني وهي
تعتمد على عقدك وتعتمد على خبرتك يعني
مثلا انت فاتح لك مركز اول وعندك خبره
كامله في المركز الثاني سهل معك فانت عارف
ممكن تاخذ افضل شيء لكن اذا هي مثلا اول
مركز لك خذ الموضوع بحذر اكثر حلو
العميل هذا متوفر فيه لا والتعقيم يعني
يعني استهلاكيه ما هي ذاك يعني كلها
متقاربه وكلها فاحرص انك صح انه في بعض
المواد تفرق كثير بس انه مثل ما قلت لك
يعني حاول انك تحرص على انه يعطيك ياخذ
افضل حاجه والتعامل مع الموردين هل في شيء
المفروض الواحد يكون طبعا لما تبدا تاسس
مرحله عيادتك بعضهم مليانه شوي مليون يبي
يفتح عياده قالوا
الاجهزها على طول
كذا لا تكيش خذ اقساط هم يوفرون لك اياها
ويعطونك فتره سماح وانت اذا خلصت مثلا
خلاص موضوع المقاول وخلصت او بعد استجاره
المبنى وتجهيزك المخطط واتفاقك مع المقاول
لازم تروح تشرب توقع برضو عقد اشراف مع
مهندس اجهزه طبيه عشان يشرف على التمديدات
هذه لا يصير فيها ليكيج تسريب ولا شيء اي
مقاول مع المهندس هذا ولا مقاول اذا هو
عنده خبره طبيب يكون اسهل اذا ما مو مشكله
اي مقاول بس اهم شيء المهندس المهندس هذا
لازم يكون موجود معك مهندس اجهزه طبيه
بيطلع لك مشكله بعدين من المواسير
هذه لابد انك لابد انك تحرص في هذه النقطه
بعد ما تخلص موضوع التمديدات وهذه خلاص
ركبت الان الاناره بس انت خلال الفتره هذه
اخذت جولات وعرفت وش الاجهزه اللي انت
ناوي تاخذها في هذه المرحله وقت تركيب
الاضاءه ابدا تعاقد حيث اذا انت مثلا مجمع
ممكن اجهزه كبيره فلابد تتعاقد من بدري
لكن عياده تلقاها في اي مستودع عندهم اصلا
هيوفروا لك اياها على طول تبدا تحاقد في
هذه في هذا الوقت قصدي اذا خلصت تشطيب اذا
خلصت الامور بعض المستعجل ويتاخر على
المقاومه هذي
تخلص وبعدين تبدا تتعاقد بس تكون انت عارف
ايش بتاخذ
تعقد في الاجهزه
تطلب فتره سماح
[موسيقى]
يعطيك في لك حق اعطوك اياه فانت قاعد تاخذ
غرامه بعد ثلاث خطوات كلهم ما شاء الله
يعني ههه الا انك مستحق وعندك نقص خبره
هذه الاشكاليه احنا نجي نقول فائده خمس
سنوات سبع سنوات واستثمار في نفسك اصلا
عرفت وراح توفر كثير حلو قلنا تكلمنا
ذلك في الكوادر الطبيه الان طبعا حتى تدخل
الكوادر طبيه او الكوادر غير طبيه
طبعا اكواد الطبيه عندك ثلاث انواع من
التعاقد طبعا اذا انت عيالك
انا خلاص طبيب ممكن طبيب عام وجي اقدر
استلم الحالات هذه كلها اللي ما تطلع
قبلتي فليش احتاج تعاقد مع ناس زياده او
اطباء
خارج خبرتك مستحيل اوكي يعني تخص الطب
الاسنان انها تتكلم عن تخصصات كثير
وتخصصات دقيقه جدا
ما كل شيء متقنين ترى في تخصصات معينه
لازم تكون موجوده يعني مثلا تكون زراعه
اصلا حتى الامتزاز السريريه
ما تسمح تسوي تقويم بس التخصصات الثاني
ممكن تحت اشراف استشاري عندك
في قيود في شيء معين لانه دقيق جدا والخطا
يعني لا يغتفر لا يغتفر يعني مثلا ما ودي
اخوف بس انه الخطا لا يختفر
[موسيقى]
تنظيف
في افكار بس ما تنجح لكن بقول لك هي ثلاث
موديل يعني ثلاث نماذج للتعاقد مع الاطباء
بشكل عام يا انه يكون براتب كامل خلاص هذا
يجيك فول تايم دوام كامل دوام كامل او انه
يكون الدوام جزئي دوام جزئي وهذا في
الغالب يصلح للموظفين الحكوميين مثلا عن
طريق خبير وكذا يجي دوام جزئي بنسبه ما هو
براتب كامل من قيمه المراجعه او العلاج
العلاج يعني ياخذ منه كم ياخذ تقريبا
والله تختلف النسب ممكن 45 45 50% 40 من
اي شيء يصرفه العميل عنده مو
يعتمد على اتفاق العياده معا مثلا بعد
المواد قبل المواد في اتفاق معين يعني
مشاركه ارباح او مشاركه مبيعات
النوع الثالث وهو دائما يعني انصح فيه
اللي هو راتب ونسبه
يكون دوام كامل شايفين نظام المناديب راتب
حد ادنى وبعطيك
[ضحك]
وفوق النسبه ايه
عنده فبالتالي هذا يكون عدده قليل ترى ما
هو كثير لو بجيب يعني خلينا نقول بالحد
الادنى اللي يحتاجه من الاطباء دوام جزئي
اذا انت عندك خبره كبيره تحتاج مثلا
الزراعه وحتحتاج التقويم هم التخصصات اللي
صعب انك تطور نفسك عشان ممكن يعني
تركيبات يكون معك او كذا يعني بس انه في
الغالب هو التقويم الزراعي اللي صعب انك
تحصلهم وبرنامج امتيازات السريريه ذكرت
انه لازم تكون تحت اشراف استشاري فتقدر
تجيب
ما هي مشكله مو لازم يكون
تقريبا كم تكون الدوام الجزئي مثل ما قلت
لك يكون نسبه تعطيهم
اصلا تقنع طبيب
يجيك
بعد القرار هذا انه في ناس ممكن
طلعك حاولوا عادات وبعدين كلهم بيروحون
يكلمون نفس الاشخاص اللي تعالوا اشتغلوا
في نفس الوقت
[موسيقى]
قلنا خبير ضخ برضو اعداد كبيره ترى
خبير ضخها اداه كبيره
ما راح يتعب المفروض الواحد
بس انه دائما كم عمر العياده هذا يجعله في
تحدي انه انا بجيك كذا بس العيادتك مشتغله
هل فيها اداره كويسه هل فيها انا ما راح
اشتغل معك وبعدين فجاه اكتشف انك بعد انت
قاعد تلخبط في اتجاه اخر مشكله البيض
والدجاجه انا الحين ما اقدر اشغل عيلتي
لين ما يكون معي اثنين واثنين هذول يبغون
علاقاتك يعني انت خمس سنوات ايش سويت
والله بنيت علاقات الناس وثقت فيك عرفت
اشتغلت في مجمعات كثير يعني عرفتها انت
صار لك اسم الناس تحترموه دائما شوف
التجاره فيها ثقه لازم يكون يثقون فيك
وثقوا فيك حيجونك لكن انت وكبادي امس
متخرج اليوم تفتح من اللي يثق انه
مشترط موضوع الخبره خمس سبع سنين
لابد تكون علاقات لازم تعرف كيف الاداره
وش الاخطاء اللي تصير قدام عينك وكيف يتم
معالجتها انت تتعلم في فلوس حلال في حلالك
على قدك
مجمعات كبيره وعرفت الامور هذه ما هو برضو
حتى لما تروح المجمع انك تقفل حياتك وخلاص
لازم تعرف وتكون صداقاتك وعلاقاتك وتقويها
من حين الناس تبدا تساعدك ولا غير الاطباء
عندك
ما تقدر تتحمل رواتب يعني الرواتب دائما
يعني تبتدي اخصائيين الى استشاريين تبتدي
فل تايم يعني تتكلم من
17 الى يصوم في 35 اوكي بالنسبه لك
كل واحد
مثلا دكتور فلان حيجي مثلا يوم واحد وحق
الزراعه يوم الرضا
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
عندنا طاقه
مسالمه
فهي الحمايه من الاشاعره الاشعاع اللي هو
الاشعه لها اجهزه معينه تلبس الممرضه
ياخذونها يجلسونها عشان يحمونها من كثر
تعرض للشعاع في غير يعني بطريقه صحيحه مضر
للصحه ممكن حتى يوقفونها على العمل وهي
عقود سنويه ولا اي عقود يعني تقريبا
ممكن 5000 هذا ممكن تقريبا في حدود
25 بشكل شهري طبعا نفاذ طبيه بشكل اسبوعي
يجي ياخذ طبيه من عندك يعطيك تقرير
وزيارات وزاره الصحه تقارير هذه وينها
الحمايه من الاشعاع
يجونك بشكل شهري ياخذون الاجهزه حقت
التمريض المسؤولين عن الاشعه يقيسونها
يتاكدون ان ما تعرضوا الاشياء عاليه
ويتاكدون طبعا غرفه الاشعه البانوراميه
مرصصه ترى وهذه في اخر خطوه
فيها رصاص الواح رصاص عشان تمنع الاشعه
انه يطلع برا
ويقيسونها هم يتاكدون الاشعه يطلعوا في
غرفه الاشعه
الباب برضه ترى
ما هي مكلة يعني تقريبا حدود عشره
فهم يجون يختبرون انك مسوي الرصاص بشكل
صحيح وانه ما في تسرب شاي وانه المرضى
مسؤول عن اشعه ما تتعرض تعرض جسمه الاشعه
يعني بشكل كبير في حدود
الوضع الطبيعي فهذه تجي بشكل شهري فهذا
العقود عند التشغيل
غير الكود الطبيه في موظف استقبال موظف
استقبال لازم هنا انت تسعين اذا انت
بتبتدي وكذا لازم يكون عنده خبره لازم
خبره ودائما انصح اي احد يوظف اي يعني اي
مستثمر بيوظف اي
كوادر طبيه يطلب منها برنت من التامينات
تاكد انه ما في تنقلات سريعه
عمليه التنقل السريع بالمنشاه المنشاه انت
توك راس مالك ضعيف ما ودك تغامل في هذا
الاتجاه
بعد اسبوع يمشي
ادفع شوي بس ما هو يشتغل بعيده قبل ولا لا
ايه تزيد بس وش الخبره اللي يعرف يتعامل
انت على خط النار
البيت طبعا المراجعين يجون بالام احيانا
فيفقد اعصابه لابد انك تعرف كيف
يعني تتعامل معه
وفي ناس يعني لطيفين وفي ناس سيئين وفي
الخبره راح تعطيك طريقه التعامل بشكل
ايجابي معه وخلنا نقول لك حد ادنى كم شخص
تحتاج يعني تقريبا ثلاثه كوادر المسانده
وبالاضافه حيكون اربعه
[موسيقى]
الاطباء انت واثنين اطباء يعني هذا
يعني ثنتين وواحده معك في العياده وواحده
برضو مسؤول عن الاشعه مسؤول عن المشتريات
يتم تدريب بشكل جيد وعندك اللي هو
الاستقبال واحد وعندك اللي هو
المنظف او المسؤول عن نظافه المكان
ممكن او انك تستخدم وتدربه شيء راجعلك
طبعا هذولي اربعه طبعا انت تكون الطبيب
الرئيسي ومعك اثنين اطباء في تخصصات نادره
اللي هو الزراعه
[موسيقى]
والتقويم اذا في تركيب تركيبات بيكون افضل
اذا ما قدرت هذا اقل شيء تحتاجه حاليا
طبعا نيجي ننقطه مهمه اللي هي انت خلاص
اسست العياده ضبطت امورك
تعاقدت خلصت
ترخيص مبدئي من وزاره الصحه قبل ما تسوي
اي شيء
تتعاقد مع المالك الامور الموقع تمام من
وزاره الصحه من بلديه تاخذ شفهيا الامور
تمام اوكي تتعاقد تاخذ عقلك تاخذ ترخيصك
كل مبدا من وزاره الصحه بعد كذا تاخذ
ترخيص المبد من البلديه تخلص امورك بعدين
البلديه ترخيص النهائي طبعا عندك شيء اسمه
الدفاع المدني لازم شركه خاصه الدفاع
المدني عشان تعطونك ترخيص دفاع مدني عندك
بعدها لازم يكون مكتمل عنده رخصه اتمام
بناء ترى
[موسيقى]
هذه مرتب الكوادر معك ومدربهم اذا ما عندك
خبره لازم تدرب تسوي شي اسمه سوفت اوبنج
افتح تجريبي اول شهر شهرين اوكي والله
تمام
اذا انت مجمع او عياده اذا عياده لا انت
خلاص كافي تمام لكن اذا مجمع فيه نقطه
اضافيه لازم يكون عندك اخصائي اول نقطه
المجمعات بس الان خلاص انا فتحت الترخيص
كلها تمام بديت تجريبي ومنين اجيب العمله
شلون نسوي طبعا
تبدا هنا عندك خبر تسويقيه ما عندك خبر
تسويق
[موسيقى]
ثقافه العماليه في التسويق الرقمي قاعد
تقدم لك دورات مجانيه الموظف قطاع خاص
سعودي مجانا كلمات
اللازمه لان هذا يعتبر استثمار في نفسك
افضل منك بعدين تروح تجيب شركه تسوق قد
تكون اصلا مهجحه
انه تايمز الوقت
فبالتالي محسوب عليك ايجار وكوادر ورواتب
فانت لك خيارين يعني يكون عندك خبره واخذت
هذا الطريق خبره تسويقيه في السوشيال
ميديا والامور هذه او انك تجيب شركه تسويق
تبي تسوق لك تمام فمن هنا يبدا يجي
العملاء طبعا اللوحاتكم امورك معارفك
المرضى فبالتالي راح شوي شوي تنطرق ومثل
ما قلت لك سلاحك وحشتي الصدق والامانه هذا
راح توصلك باسرع ما يمكن بالاضافه قدرتك
القدره الطبيه والقدره التعامل مهارات
التواصل اذا عادي عندك انتهى الموضوع
الناس هم اللي بيجيبوا لك ناس اكتب
الاطب المتمكن جدا قليل جدا قليل
العياده الاسنان انهم يطلعوا لنا في سناب
تجون فتره كذا يعلنون سبعين عياده يحطون
وحده هي تطلع تتكلم في الاعلان انا ما
ادري صراحه
عروض الشتاء والصيف
وتعال الخصم
خدمه طبيه حتى لو هو اعلانك لازم يكون
بشكل احترافي افضل صراحه
بهالشكل يعني عرفت لابد انك اول حاجه
توزن الامور تعرف يعني احنا مقبرين الايام
الجايه ان شاء الله على الله احيانا على
اللي هو اليوم الوطني يوم الوطني كلنا حتى
نوصل سعر تكلفه فاين يعني هو احتفال فممكن
توصل لكن مو بتجين تقول عروض شتاء عروض
سيف
عروض عيد
ما تشوفها تسويق زياده شف كثره العروض انت
قاعد تقدم خدمه طبيه انسانيه
فلما انت تربطه بالعروض فاك كانك تتكلم
بالماده اكثر هذا وجهه نظر شخصيه انا بفضل
صراحه انه لا اتكلم عن الخدمه عن التثقيف
الصحي
عن خدماتك تقدمها عن جوده علاجك تقدمه عن
التعقيم عن يعني هذه الامور عن تجربه
مميزه للمراجع هذا اللي تسويق الحقيقي
اللي يكون ثابت اساسا ثابت مثل ما تشوفون
العميل يتوجه للارخص بدل ما يروح الاجود
ارخص افضل من الاجود شوف بعلمك حاجه انت
عندك نوعين من العملاء
تصنيف برضو شخص
عميل جايك من باب العياده وعميل جايك من
عوائل
عوائل عوائل مثلا والله
اخوي مشهور بيان تعرف دكتور فهد الدكتور
فهد هو دكتور العائله حتى الان في تخصصات
جديده في هي التخصصيه اسمها
طبيب الاسنان العائله
فهذا المفهوم هو المفهوم الحقيقي في ارض
الواقع
بالنسبه اللي يجيك من باب العياده في
تحديات كبيره انه اول شيء طبيب مخلص قدم
له كل الخيرات العلاج ما بتختارها لنفسك
انت مع نسب النجاح لها الحق اني اختار
المراجع في اختيار انت تعرض الخيارات
ويختار
[موسيقى]
يبحث عن خدمته في ايضا مسار اخر اشوف
الاطباء بشكل عام او بعض الاطباء يدفعونه
اللي هو يسيرون مشاهير سوشيال ميديا اللي
يسوي الحساب يتكلم عن الامور هذه او يروج
او ايا كانت
قاعد تحسب الاجر وهذا شيء ايجابي وبرضو
انت اذا الناس يعرفوك يا هلا ومرحبا
لكنك
سوشيال ميديا بشكل يعني
غير صحيح او بشكل تشكيك قبل فتره يعني
مثلا انه قريت انه يقول تصريف الطبيب
اسنان يقول
الفم مستخدمه هاي تصريفه هذا الكلام
طبعا هو خارج السعوديه فانت ما تقدر
تدخل في الذمام ولا تقدر تشكك فيها فغير
صراحه محبب انك تبحث عن ترند بطريقه هذه
تحاول تثير الجدل اثاره الجدل هذا خاصه
الناس عندهم فوبيا وعندهم خوف وعندهم يعني
تجارب احيانا قد تكون سيئه في عدسه فلما
يسمع الكلام هذا خلاص طلع الطبيب برضو
كاذب
تقعد خربت الموضوع كامل هذا غير صحيح وهذا
اصلا كتصريفه اذا هي تصرفات فرديه فهي
تصرفات فرديه لا يؤخذ فيها مجتمع طب
الاسهم بشكل كامل عرفت تعميم دائما لغه
غير صحيح هذا لغه الجهلاء
طيبه جدا
عن طريق مشاهير مثلا شوف العينات في
البدايه تحتاجها فقط
لكن الاعتمادك دائما على الاعلانات انت
عندك مشكله خدمه الكرت في اشكاليه ترى
ما تقدر تميز نفسك الاعلان يعني اقدر مثلا
لو انا شركه خلنا نقول شركه اتصالات شركه
اتصالات اقدر اقول هذه الباقه درفيها كذا
كذا تختلف عن منافسي انتم كلكم
ما تقدر تروج الا بالخصومات لا تجربه
العميل ما بعد الخدمه هذه تراها مفقوده
تماما
كيف يعني انت لا يعني مثلا بعد الخدمه
اتصل عليه اطمن عليه ونشوف ايش صار اذا هم
مسوي عمليه جراحيه كبيره ولا مسوي شيء
عندك يعني كان بالم شديد جاك فخدمه ما بعد
الخدمه او ما بعد العمليه الطبيه هذه
مفقوده للامانه
يقول الناس اوف والله هذول عندهم شوف
الاعلان انت تحتاجه مبدئيا ترى
اللي يعتمد على الاعلام بشكل دائم هذا
عنده مشكله في الريتنشن حق حق المراجعه
هذا عنده مشكله لازم ترجع نفسك تراجع
سياساتكاليه هي المفروض يعني انت ست شهور
سنه وخلاص توقف عنها لانك اذا قدرت تحافظ
على المراجعين
العوائل اللي احنا نتكلم عنها من هنا انت
بديت تنطلق وورد ماوس كلمه المراجح يصدق
شيء دعايه المراجع نفسه هي اصدق شيء واسهل
شيء وتجيب لك نوعيه ممتازه من المراجعين
المجمعات وايش تفرق المجمعات اذا انت مثلا
تستثمر ولا طبيب ما شاء الله الله يفتح
عليك طبعا هو مسموح لك كمستثمر غير طبيب
ومسموح كطبيب انك تفتح كمجمع طبعا هنا
التحديات ترى تكبر
يعني احنا نتكلم اول عن عياده الاخطاء
محفوفه
وتلحقها بدري
وتقدر تتلافى امور كثيره يعني في يعني
الهدر عندك قليل
والتكلفه التشغيليه قليله التحديات اقل
ممكن تجي مثلا مواد طلبتها انت تاريخها
لازم
استخدمته ما استخدمته ما استخدمته صار هدر
انتهى تاريخ كم تصلحيتها
احيانا تستمر سنه سنتين ثلاثه يعتمد على
المورد تبغى
[ضحك]
ببحث عن موزعين
فلا بد انك تبحث عن الامور هذه يعني بتكون
عندك اسمها
يعني حسن التدبير حسنه لازم يكون عندي هذه
مهارات ترى
في المجمعات يمكن نسبه خطا اكبر اكبر
اموال بشريه اكثر اضافيه لازم يكون عندك
اخصائي اول في تخصص طب الاسنان هذا واحد
المدير الطبي لازم يكون طبيب سعودي
المدير الاداري لازم يكون سعودي مع
البكالوريوس باي تخصص
طبي او غير طبي ما يهمم لازم يكون عندك
شو اسمه نسبه السعوده في الاطباء وهذه
مشكوره وزاره المواد البشريه قاعد تحاول
انه
يعني تدخل حدثي التخرج في القطاع الخاص
انه ياخذوا هذه الخبره فالزمان 30% نسبه
جدا ضخ
عندك لازم يكونون سعوديه
فهذا جزء من المجمعات العامه برضو تاييد
الكوادر ما يعطونه
قدمتها وزاره الصحه
الغير السعودي اللي موجودين
انت لما تيجي مثلا خاص عندك
داخل البلد غير سعودي حتبحث عن
في البلدان العربيه
عن طبيب في التخصص هذا فعشان تاخذ الفيزا
لازم تكون عندك شيء اسمه تعديل الكواد
تاييد كوادر عشان تطلع الفيزا هذه تسمح لك
وزاره المواد
اوكي هذه مش تستحق مثلا خمس فيز سبع فيز
زي كذا الفيز هذه مكتوب فيها تخصص اذا هم
عندهم مربوطين في التخصص صحيه ترى في شغل
جبار بس المشكله اللي يراهم الخارج يحسد
ترى شغل مره احترافي مربوطين بهيئه قصص
صحيه يعرفوا وين التخصصات اللي صار فيها
امتلاء من السعوديه
راح يبحث عنها ففي تاييد وفيه محاوله
ادخال الشباب السعودي والنهضه فيه لان هو
ترى الاساس هو الاستثمار هو حيبتدي طبيب
الان بكره راح يصير اونر حيصير عنده
عيادات عنده مجموعات ناخذ مثال حبيبي الله
يوفقه يعني هو احد الناس اللي تدخلوا في
القطاع الخاص والان عنده سلاسل يعني كبيره
فهذه هي الفكره انه ندخل ندخله الان ياخذ
الخبره ينجح ينطلق حلو والاختلاف في
التكاليف ما بين
التشغيليه المجمع والعياده انه غير طبعا
مساله المساحه والعياده اكثر نفس التكاليف
تكبر وفي اشراطات على كوادر اضافيه هذا
كلهم لازم يكونون تايم صح لازم يكون
ارتفاع في
التكاليف يعني تضرب بنفس التكاليف العياده
خمسه ولا سته
طبعا عشان كذا نقول تكلفه انشاء مجمع ثلاث
عيادات ممكن يوصلوا من 380 يعني مبلغ ضخم
ترى مو بسيط وين عقدتك طويل أملك قصير امد
لازم تربط امورك لازم تعرف تعمل يلا افتح
عشان
تكلمنا على جانب الايرادات الحين كم يعني
هم الربح لو بتحسبها اليوم جاك مريض اول
شيء كيف تساعد اساسا المرض هلو نتعرف عليه
تقول الكل مراجعه او الحشوه كذا
العصب كذا هل في اسعار موحده هل تقدر تحط
انت الطبيب تقول والله تكاليف عاليه باصقع
السعر فوق لان علي طلب يعني شلون موضوع
التسعير طبعا انت لازم اول شيء تدرس في
السوق
انت لازم تصير ابن سوق اسمها ابن سوق لازم
تدرس السوق تعرف العيادات وش قاعد تقدم وش
تسعيرتها تعرف موقعك وين انت
خدماتك وشركات تقدمها في اي بي اي بي سي
لازم تحدد
هاي تصني
عيادات مره
حقتها او قائمه اسحارها مره نازله وفي
عيادات متوسطه وفي عيادات جدا انت وين
خدماتك وش تشبه من السوق لازم تعرف انت
لازم تعرف منافسك منهم
المنافسي مثل عياده متدنيه
متوسط او متوسط الخدمه عاليه الخدمه لازم
تحدد
فبناء عليه انت تتشابه معاهم
تتشابه معاهم ولازم تكون انت منافس فالسعر
وفي الخدمه
لازم تصير منافس السعر وفي الخدمه مثل
قطاع الكافيات لازم السعر لازم منافس
الخدمه هذا نفس الشيء
تكاتنعدم في البدايات ترى
رسوم المطلوبه منك الجهه تحكميه مدفوعه
مدفوعه انت لازم تعرف انت عندك شيء بس انه
كل ما اشتغلت اكثر كل ما قدرت تغطي هذا
البوتيم لاين وقد تطلع فوقه اوكي ما اقدر
اقول لك ان هامش الربح كذا عندك لازم تعرف
هل هي عياده هل هي مجمع كم عياده
اي خدمه ثانيه انت تحتاج تغطي التكاليف
وانت شطارتك تقدر ترفع ربك الناس تعرفوك
وصار عندك خدمه مميزه حتصير انت تطلع تصير
وقتك الثمان ساعات قاعد تقضيها عندك فيها
مرضى ما عندك وقت فاضي
كذا نشوف مراجعه واحد في اليوم
[موسيقى]
اخذته شخصيه وجه شبه ثاني ترى يمثل طب
الحشوه هذا اعلى شيء انت لما تحدد
لازم تدرس منافس بعدين تقدم قائمه اسعار
كل القطاع الخاص القطاع الخاص يعتمد لك
اياه اللي هو اداره القطاع الخاص في
الشؤون الصحيه التي تتبع لها المنطقه
يختمون لك عليها ولازم تعرض في مكان بارز
عريسبشن
بناء على ايش حطيتها دراسه السوق بس هم ما
يفرق معاهم هل هو بنيه ولا ب500 لا يعني
اذا كان مره اكيد انه حيصير الاشكاليه
عندك اذا مثلا انت حددتها مثلا 200 رحت
سويت 400 بس
ما طلبوا يعتمدونها الا انه في مشكله صارت
فيبون
واقعي لا تصير يعني انت لازم تدرس السوق
انت لا تاخذ عباطه بحط 2000 وحيجون يدفعون
2000 وش الاسم الكبير اللي حيجي يدفع لك
2000 وانت توك داخل انت لازم تعرف منافسك
وش قائمه اسعاره بناء عليه تحد ممكن حتى
تنزل عنه لازم انت
تصير منافس السعر وفي الخدمه بعدين لما
تحط قائمه اسعار تروح تعتمدها من وزاره
الصحه هنا يا ويلك تتعداها خلاص وقره خلاص
تعرضهم كان بارز يشتكي مراجعه انك تعديتها
الحشوه ب 300 استحمل جزائك
تمام
مراجعه يشتكي تدير اساسا تجربه المراجعين
شلون تاكد مثلا
العميل هذا راضي عن
الخدمه المقدمه وفعلا مثلا بعد لان عندكم
مشكله انه ممكن المشاكل تبين بعد ست شهور
بعد سنه مستحيل تقعد تتابع مع العميل ده
كل الفترات هذه فهل في اجراء معين عشان
تقدر تحكم الجوده في العياده عندك او حتى
في يعني اي طبيب يحكم الجوده في العيادات
الثانيه الاطباء يشتغلون معه فيها ولا انه
يشد حيله يدعي ربنا
لا شوف دائما هنا يجي التحديات التشغيليه
هذه اسمها
الجوده اذا انت ما ضبطتها حترجع للبراند
حقك على اسمك تمام كمركز طبيب فتره تعاقد
يستمع معك ولا يمشي انت كمركز ولا هو ترى
المفترض الطبيب عنده تامين ضد اخلاق طبيه
مثل السيارات
طبيه لو ارتكب خطا طبي شركه التامين تعوض
هذا المتضرر اذا ثبت انه خطا طبي بس انا
برضو تخاف على سمعتك اكثر
بس الارث اللي حققه ما بين جوده او جوده
انت اللي هتاخذه
فبالتالي لابد انك تكون سريع وفعال في
اتخاذ الاجرام لازم تتابع هنا عشان كذا لو
تقولي مثلا ناخذ السؤال بطريقه اخرى تنصح
مستثمر غير طبي غير طبيب انه يدخل السوق
الان في 2023 او اطباء فقط اقول لك
الغير طبيب والله صعب عليه ان يعرف الجوده
طيب
نعرف عليه الجوده فبالتالي انت راح يكون
عيارك شيء واحد كم دخل طبيبتي
وبعضهم يمثل لك احلى تمثيل انا والله انا
ترطيب شاطر وانا ادخلي كويس وانا وانت
تنغر فيه اي والله والناس تحبه من ضمن 50%
اللي قلناهم عندهم مهاره التواصل بس ما
عند المهارات الطبيه الكافيه او المهارات
المميزه فبالتالي بعد فتره تبين اخطاء
علاجيه
فتكتشف متاخر هذا الاشكاليه فالعب في
البراند حقك
لابد انك تكون طبيب وعارف وش المعيار
انه تركيباتكم ثابته صح ما فيها فراغات
علاج العصب يكون واصل ذروه السن وهذا انت
بنفسك بس اذا انت جايب الاثنين اللي معك
عشان تفتح عياده انت لازم عقودك تكون
محدده معهم ترى في جوده وفي عندي كذا
ومعايير الجوده عندي كذا وتراها كذا وفيها
خصومات تتحملها الله يعطيك العافيه
للالعاده العلاج لو صار فيه اشكاليه عندي
انت لازم تحمي براند حقك
هذه تكون فيها زي القايد لاينز
سنوات سبع سنوات
جدا عالي فصار يعني ترى فاهم وعارف
فبالتالي انت لازم تلعب على موضوع الجوده
ما تلعب على موضوع
[موسيقى]
العدد ترى هذا انتهى ما هو بهذا الوقت
اليوم السوق تعتقد انه يتسع لعدد كبير من
العيادات الاضافيه انا اقول دائما في
لوحات كثير بس ترى اطب متمكنين قليل والله
اقولها وانا متاكده ومسؤول يعني عن هذه
الكلمه اطب المتمكنين اللي عليهم الكلام
قليل اللوح في لوحات كثيره
فتختلف الامور انا اشوف انه الان الوقت في
شح كبير لطميه متميزين
فيش كبير وش المشكله
ما هو مشكله هي هي بس مثل ما قلت زمان كنا
نتمنى كلنا وظائف حكوميه
الان بدينا ندخل القطاع الخاص يعني كاطباء
اسرار اتكلم فبالتالي بدينا نتعرف على
القطاع الخاص
مسيطر عليه
المجمعات الضخمه اللي تتبع الشركات الكبرى
شوف انا صعب انك لحالك
لا انا اقول لا مستحيل ان احد يسيطر على
طب الاسنان مستحيل لانه هي خدمه هي خدمه
يعني
انت هي مثل رسام مثل رسام انت ترسم في
لوحات تنباع ترى مئات الملايين وفي لوحه
بخمسه ريال
ترى يفرق معاه مهاره ليش هذا رسام طيب لا
هذا رسام عليه الكلام هذا رسام فالطبيب
لابد يكون عند المهاره القويه اللي يقدر
ينافس فيه مثلا ما هو منتج ان الشركه تجي
تصنع
في النهايه انا هنا اجيب معنى هذه توصيه
متواضعه مني ولكن ارى انها لها في عمليات
شركات
متخصصه
تاسس وتساعد في التشغيل انا اتمنى ان هذا
الموديل يكون موجود والصراحه هذا الموديل
غير موجود والمنافسه فيه صفر وانا هنا
صراحه اشوف اخترع هذا الاقتراح على شركه
صح القابضه على صندوق استثمارات العامه
لانه ترى ما تجربح فيه عادي وانا اجيك
كطبيب اعطيك المبلغ وانت تسوي
الان شفت التحديات قديش كبيره كطبيب درسه
سبع سنين من عمره ترى هذه يحتاجها سبع
سنين ثانيه عشان فبالتالي انت ممكن تطلب
منهم خبره معينه
مثلا ثلاث سنوات خمس سنوات سبع سنوات
وتسوي الانترفي وتتاكد منه وبعدين خلاص
انا اجي انشئ لك العياده واساعدك التشغيل
واخذ منك هامش ربح وانت مسؤول عن خسارتك
ترى تقدم اهلا وسهلا
مكتب صغير
ويساعدونك في اختيار الكوادر ويشغلون لك
التشغيل ويساعدونك اشرافيا
وين تنطلق
الطب المتميزين حافز يعني
عمليه الدخول في السوق لان فيه خوف وحذر
وراس مال يحتاج في تخوف لكن هذه حتعطيه
جراءه اكثر اتمنى هذا المنتج صراحه يدخل
سواء من شركات اللي هي حكوميه او شبه
حكوميه او حتى القطاع الخاص بشكل عام هذا
الموديل اللي انا شفنا ناجح وغير موجود
ترى غير موجود لو بنقول
ابرز ثلاث مشاكل يواجهون
او في اداره عياده في اداره العياده ثلاث
مشاكل اساسيه هي
عدم الوصول للجوده الى اقصى حد ممكن هذا
تحدي مره كبير
تحدي تسرب الوظيفي
اداره الكواد البشريه انت مطلوب منك
مهارات كبير منها شو اسمه
كانك تفهم في الاتش ار وتفهم في الاي تي
وتفهم عندك مهارات كثيره لازم تكون عندك
اقل شيء خلفيه فيها او عندك من يساعدك
فيها
كذلك
العمليات التفاوض يعني انا واحده من مواقف
اذكرها كان
يعني وصلني فيها خبر انه في عياده عاقده
مع الشركه
مواد تبييض قيمه الماده هي اصلا تقريبا
كان 1000 كانت 800 ارض يعني بس تشتري منه
ب 30,000
ونعطيك معها جهاز هديه ونعطيك انبسط صاحب
العياده وقع معاهم بس مسها ترى لها تاريخ
انتهاء هل تقدر تخلص
الكميه هذه تاريخ الانتهاء هذا هنا لا
يصير عندك مهارات التفاوض في اخطاء تصير
احيانا في اخطاء
بس الاخطاء الخبره تقلل منها
طيب
بالنسبه تقول الحين في فرصه كبيره السوق
في تنظيم الان يسمح الاطباء السعوديين انه
يشغلون عياداتهم ويشتغلون في القطاع الخاص
بس بنفس الوقت من فتره وفتره تسمع عن
بطاله الاطباء السعوديين فرص وملاقين
انه احس في شيء يعني
طبعا هنا برضه حتى نشوف الجود ممنوع مثلا
في هيئه قصص صحيه هيئه قصص صحيه صراحه
مشكوره قدمت ان البورد السعودي كان في
اغلب التخصصات اربع سنوات قال له ثلاث
سنوات مع الحفاظ على مخرجات التعليم
وجودتها
بحيث انه يواكبون انه في اعداد كبيره تدخل
القطار خاص تمام بالاضافه برضو الى انه
الطبيب خلال فتره هذي يدفع الراتب وزاره
الصحه يعني خلال تدريب يشجعون على انه
يطور من نفسه وينطلق
كل هذه عوامل قاعده تحفز الاشكاليه هي
ترجع الاطب العامين هي الاشكاليه ترى تخص
في الغالب الاطب العامي
الطبيب العام يكون اخص ست سنوات في دراسه
الاندر جراند اللي هو دراسه الجامعه يصل
سنه الامتياز
بعضهم ياخذ راحه او بعضهم ما يعرف امتياز
بشكل هو
انت لو قدرت انك تطور من نفسك امتياز
لانها هي تسمحك تدخل المستشفيات الحكوميه
والمستشفيات المرجعيه وتحت اشراف استشاريه
متمكنين حاول تطور نفسك في علاج العصب
حاول تطول نفسك في الخلع شد الهمه شوي ترى
هذه اهم سنه اهم سنه هذه تصقلك الاشكاليه
انهم يتخرجون انه المهارات الطبيه طبعا
انت عندك نوعين اللي يجيب بنسبه كبيره قد
تكون 60% احيانا هو الالم
قوي اتجاه العياده طيب لما يجيب الالم ايش
سبب الالم هو علاج عصب
يحتاجه فانت لازم من الثنتين هذه متقنها
يعني وهذه هي جواز سفرك اللي راح يدخلك
العيادات الخاصه لما يكون معك المهارات
الطبيه اللازمه متقنها بشكل كبير ما انت
ماخذك انت دفانس فيها متطور فيها هذا طبيب
العامه طبعا المشكله يعلمون في الجامعه
تعلمك
لكن الدائري تتعلموا في الامتياز فاذا
تعلمت في امتياز قدرت تدخل القطاع الخاص
القطاع الخاص يقدر يتبناك في موضوع اخر
اطول منك مثلا في اداره الوقت في
حسن التدبير في تعاملك مع البيشنت فيه هذه
يقدر يقطع الخاص يتبناك فيها لكن اذا انت
ما عندك المهارات الطبيه اللي هي ادفاس
مثلا
علاج العصب والخلايا انت ما راح تكون مفيد
كثير يعني يعني انت بتلعب على العياده
بتوقع هذا بموضوع كبير وساهم بنسبه مره
كبيره كبيره وهنا الاشكاليه ترى هذه
الاشكاليه انا هنا ادعو صراحه مثلا خاصه
الان الجامعات مثلا انه مثلا امتياز سودوا
دورات تدريبيه حتى لو فلوس يا اخي خارج
اوقات العمل سول الدورات التدريبيه ويحرص
على تطور مثلا في علاج العصب في الخلع او
انه خلال تدريب في امتياز احرص عليه في
هذه الاشياء ان تكون عنده مثلا متطلبات
معينه يخلصها هنا راحوا ينطلق القطاع
الخاص بكل قوه
عرفت لكن لما يكون هو فاقد المهارات
الاساسيه المهارات الطبيه اللازمه للقطاع
الخاص ومهارات التواصل انت حتصير حيوظفك
سته شهور ثمان شهور
في بعضهم
نفسي
انت الان لا ترى من سبق الان بخطوتين
والله فلان والله توظف في وظيفه فلانيه
مثلا او في مكان معين وياخذ الراتب
الفلاني يا اخي لا ترى من نسبك الان
بخطوتين لانك حتسبقه كيلو مترات في
الفيوتشر
يجمع هذا ليجمع الان خلال سنه انت
عشر سنوات حتجمع خلال سنه سنتين انتظر لها
كذا انت حاول تكون عندك شغف يحب هذا
التخصص وفي تطوير نفسك فيه لا تجي تفكر
انه انكم اخذ انا كم انت ما وصلت مرحله
انك تاخذ انك تعطي
بعدين اخذ يعني انت عمرك شفت مثلا كطالب
مثلا انك تاخذ الدرجه قبل الاختبار لازم
تختبر وتعطي المجهود وتاخذ درجه تستحقه
ترى زي كذا هي الحياه انت لازم تروح
للقطاع الخاص وتعطيه وتبذل الجهد فيه لا
تتوقع انك ترى يعني
المشكله دائما حتى على مستوى ليش اقول لك
في مثلا 30% عندهم المهارات الطبيه
اللازمه بس ما عنده مهارات الاقلاع وكذا
لانه تخرج بشهاده علميه كبيره ويجيك
احيانا نرجسيه احيانا يجيك كذا احيانا
يا اخي لا تصير كذا يا اخي ترى الشهاده هي
وراء اعطتك الاساس لكن انت من هنا تنطلق
من هنا تطور نفسك ليش في عشره في المئه
يعني مثلا الرواتب مثلا في القطاع الخاص
ترى تتراوح ما بين 4000 الى 600 الف شهر
بالشهر طبيب راحت عليك
هذا شخص اعمله فيه الناس وخدمته ممتاز
وجودته جدا عاليه وشخص متمكن في التواصل
وفي الطب شخص نادر دائما يفرض سعر
فلا يغرك ترى طب الاسنان في استثمار لان
الواحد لازم يفكر انه يستثمر في نفسه لابد
هذا اصلا عنده
مجمعات حتى بعضهم يخاف انه يفتح مجمعات
انه يخاف انه تقل جودته ترى دائما راس
المال جبان فيحاول انه خلاص انا وصلت
اكتفي عن طريق بدايته لا يقضي سنين ما
يقدر يجيب
الخطوات
لا تخاف أنت هذه القناه دائما مثل ما قلت
لك هي مفتاحين عشان توصل
يعني نجاح في طب اسرع صدق الامانه هذه اهم
حاجه الله يعطيك العافيه الله يوفق صراحه
في قطاع يمكن تكلمنا عنه ابدا في البرنامج
وهذا هو احد الاسباب اللي هو لو تواجدي
هنا انه طورنا لو بكلمه
بس اوساهمنا في تحسين مستقبل احد او في
تطوير احد بالاخير احنا مستعملين ترى يعني
في المجال الطبي واحنا عيال هذا البلد
وحريصين على المجال هذا انه يوصل للمستفيد
للكير هيلز بشكل افضل
فهذا اللي نتمناه وهذا سبب وجودنا ولعل
الله ينفع فيها ان شاء الله ويبارك في
الجهد الله يعطيك العافيه شكرا
لكم وشكرا لعبد الملك ال سعيد في انتاج
المحتوى في التحرير مرغمض بيبان في اداره
التصوير ياسر بن غانم في الاضاءه عبد
المجيد عمر الهندسه الصوتيه عبد العزيز
المزي في الاخراج الابداعي وهاب موسى
الخراج الفني مجد الملي ومساعده وسيم معين
وفي الانتاج التنفيذي غيداء التميمي هذا
السوالف بزنس احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه
للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]